and then there were two
i know you know what nobody likes us the
two [ __ ] are left
selena gomez and camila cabello they're
just like us guys having a girls night
drinking cocktails and making epic tick
tocks oh my goodness yeah it's amazing
on tuesday selena shared this clip with
her pal camila and then there were two
i know you know what nobody likes us the
two pages are left
and if that sound feels familiar
it's probably because it's from the hit
lifetime reality show dance moms and
then there were two
i know you know what nobody likes us the
two [ __ ] are left
iconic and then there were two
i know you know what nobody likes us the
two
left
in the caption cell directs her fans to
stream the 25 year old singer's new
album familiar
[Music]
of course selena's fans already know
she's a big fan of camila's music
yes
in fact she recently danced like no one
was watching to camilla's hit single
bomb bomb on tick tock writing alongside
it quote love my girl camila
[Music]
e.t recently sat down with the cuban
american singer to chat about familia
and dished on collaborating with ed
sheeran on her lead single
[Music]
he is like
my
dream feature collaborator
um and so when i sent him the song he
was like oh i love it let's definitely
do this i just felt like this is too
good to be true he's gonna change his
mind and he didn't and he's been so
excited about it throughout the x factor
alum also got candid about channeling
her heartbreak into her new music
specifically bomb bomb following her
split from shawn mendes
i started writing this song a few months
back and uh so we had this kind of
chorus idea uh about just kind of like
what it's been like in my late teens and
early twenties kind of kind of falling
in it in and out of love and the ups and
downs of that
and also reminding
myself uh as my mom has told me
in real life many times that
that's life you're on the ground crying
in the bathroom floor and then you'll
have feelings for another person again
and then you'll be crying on the
bathroom floor again
and
that is kind of like the cycles of of
change like things just change you never
know what's around the corner the two
announced their split back in november
and while camilla doesn't reference that
breakup specifically she did tell e.t
that she has a solid crew of friends and
family who helped her get back on her
feet during the tough times
talking to my friends like literally
just being like guys i'm feeling this
and this fear i'm feeling sad about this
like really being open with people
going for walks like so many different
things like i feel like that's kind of
the key to getting older is like
those feelings are gonna come and i
think you just gather
more and more tools to cope with them in
like healthy ways
listen nothing picks up my spirit like a
good old-fashioned hang with the girls
so on that note let's run selena and
camilla back one more time and then
there were two
i know you know what nobody likes those
the two [ __ ] are left
[Music]
you